hu est scotché mois il je suis bonjour
factor mais qu'en faites-vous là de
casimir ça y est ça y est quoi mais ma
chanson je connais par coeur c'est vrai
avait dit qu'à chanter à un joli
françois et aux enfants pour sûr ça me
ferait plaisir égaliser et oui mais
voici casimir je n'ose pas arriver comme
ça au milieu d'eux et leur chanter ma
chanson je n'impose pas
revenir demain alors que j'ai mise j'ai
envie de la chanter
voilà vous voulez que j'aille voir et
que je trouve un prétexte pour que vous
la chantier tout juste casimiro si tu
réussis pour sûr je te serai
reconnaissant alors de quoi parle quelle
est votre chanson mais tu le sais très
bien elle parle de tous les métiers que
j'aurais pu faire et de celui que
j'exerce ah oui d'accord bon écoute et
vous rachetez là vous vous cachez et
lorsque je vous appellerai ou bien leur
évite un au caucase et urbaco merci
julie oui casimir j'aurai une question à
se poser c'est écoutes dans quel métier
aurais-tu aimé faire baptiser bien
j'aurais aimé être artiste peintre
souviens toi de ma chanson avec beaucoup
de couleurs je suis moi je lis à l'etrat
d'allemand mais j'ai pas le temps
froid le quasi mais quels métiers ont
reculé mais faire
il a envie que je chante ma chanson il
aime beaucoup tout
un savant dresse avant c'est ce que je
n'avais pas vu ça
tu n'aimes pas ma chanson peut-être
sinon beaucoup beaucoup alors tu trouves
que je la chante mal si nous nous
françois pas du tout non non mais on
aurait peut-être pu poser cette question
aux enfants ça aurait fait en juin oui
c'est une bonne idée avec d'accord ça
marche julie vient avec nous ils ont
venez venez sur le banc
casimir vient d'avoir une très bonne
idée venez venez venez vite et nous
allons parler des métiers que nous
voulons faire tu vois c'est justement un
facteur de hausse a
dit marc là bas si le facteur je ne vois
pas casimir voici les facteurs non mais
non mais non cassini a mis au jour à
l'enfer que faisiez vous cacher derrière
la voile rouge - derrière l'arbre
il l'a fait son soulier ah oui c'est ça
je la sais monstre on soutient les
acteurs que se passe-t-il vous avez
l'air troubler les nouilles et il est en
pleine forme oui je suis en exemple
instamment nous nous étions fait de
dendrite kazimiyah c'est toi
alors facteurs pour moi avons choisi
d'être factuel et l'accouchement par les
cases émir lorsque j'étais petit j'ai
longtemps réfléchi bon d'accord mais
c'est parce que je vous demandais alors
quoi 1 à france là franchement chanterez
a franchement chanter
chanter un chant théâtre bienvenus oui
je sais ça vous voulez que je vous
chante la chanson
j'ai eu une chance formidable salesi
nous vous invitons à laisser je
plongeais où il ya les érables alors
enfin musique 1
[Musique]
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier masson geslot draps
j'aurais pu même être chaud entre
j'aurais pu être petit bassin copie
there mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être facteur
quand je suis le roi
d'orthographe
je suis l'ami des jolis mots
amoureux des phrases et ses lego
je les emporte sur mon
seul un bouchon
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier à son rouge et au gras
j'aurais pu même être chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
pour mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être impacté car je
suis le ouah de l'orthographe
j'aime les lettres
les écritures guézé charmante quand leur
taux grimperait respecter cela montchamp
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
maniema sont rouges et aux graves
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être victimes at her confie
de fou mais cale au bras mais j'ai
choisi d'être noël
je suis le droit de leur programme
dès que commence ma tournée
tout le long du chemin je chaud
les gens jettent mon arrivée cela
montchamp
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aurais plus à ton pied zager veniez
masson rouge et au gras
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mechal au bras mais je choisis d'être
pas de peur pour ceux
et je choisis des tracteurs pour sur lui
mais j'ai choisi d'être un facteur
[Musique]